la poste recrute dans les yvelines la
direction vient d'annoncer l'embauché de
145 facteurs d'ici fin 2010 est le
double de l'année dernière cette
décision fait suite à un accord national
signé fin février
ce document prévoit 3000 postiers
supplémentaires sur le territoire
français
nous notre objectif est effectivement de
recruter de recruter des personnels qui
eux vont nous permettre de renforcer
notre notre force de travail donc ça ça
reste important mais c'est pas pour
aller plus vite c'est au contraire pour
avoir des personnes qui soient plus
polyvalente plus qualifiés mais qu'ils
puissent aussi s'adapter à nos métiers
depuis le début de l'année 45 candidats
ont déjà été recrutées en cdd sur le
département
les facteurs sont payées sur la base du
smic pour entendre de travail de 35
heures leurs journées commencent tous
les jours entre 7h et 8h c'est plutôt
dans des établissements une partie de
tri de préparation du courrier dans le
sens de la tournée avec différents
produits tels que le courrier ou le
colis et puis aller à distribuer tous
les produits
autre objectif de ces recrutements
répondre à la livraison 2.0 mise en
place par la poste les nouveaux facteurs
seront formés pendant quinze jours à
leur arrivée pour maîtriser les nouveaux
outils digitaux
au début je croyais que c'était
difficile j'ai eu du mal mais je me suis
je me suis fait hier je pense que tout
le monde peut s'y faire mais moi je suis
pas tout jeune donc je pense que les
plus jeunes ils peuvent s'ils ferment
sur le mois d'avril la poste recherche
principalement des postiers sur saint
quentin en yvelines versailles
rambouillet et croissy-sur-seine aucun
diplôme spécifique n'est demandé il faut
simplement être titulaire d'un permis b
voiture